[Music]
Newsweek magazine is delivering an
important warning this Christmas season
on Sunday Newsweek published an article
saying that the Nazis and Donald Trump
quote stole Christmas to promote white
nationalism in the piece several writers
and academics warm that phrases like
Merry Christmas have become a dog
whistle showing support for whites and
veiled hatred of Muslims Jews atheists
immigrants doubtless painting Easter
eggs will soon be a hateful assault on
vegans everywhere Nell Daly is a
psychotherapist and she joins us now do
you buy into this idea that Merry
Christmas is a racist dog whistle well I
want to just talk about the article from
News weakness not necessarily what I
believe as a journalist I did some
research into this and I read the
article then I thought to myself is
there actually a war on Christmas
happening so 9 out of every 10 Americans
in the United States celebrate Christmas
so I thought okay well maybe there isn't
a war happening but what is happening in
the Pew Center which is a bipartisan
research organization came out with a
study yesterday saying that only 46% of
the people who actually celebrate
Christmas view it as a religious holiday
which is down from 51% in 2013 so in a
sense there is a changing of the tides I
don't want to say a war on Christmas but
a changing of the tides that people in
American society
are becoming less religious but none of
that surely justifies this comparison of
Trump and the Nazis that they I mean
work force up the Nazis basically
secularized Christmas they turned it
into a kind of pagan nature worship so
so if anyone's comparable to the Nazis
it's the old hippie dippie winter
solstice worshippers all dancing around
worshipping Mother Earth on December
21st or what it whatever it is I mean
isn't isn't that ridiculous just to
compare the Nazis and Trump for their
attitude to Christmas I think what the
article was suggesting and
myself I think what the article was
suggesting was that Trump is using this
language to embolden will be language
like Merry Christmas well why why it's
not just saying Merry Christmas he's
saying now the war on Christmas has
ended so the question is was there ever
a war on Christmas and when you suggest
that there was a war on Christmas you
make people feel defensive what people
feel defensive when we say that there
actually was a war what wasn't it the
people were being made to be made
defensive because they go to the
shopping mall and the clerk says happy
holidays as if there's something kind of
dirty and not quite respectable about
saying merry Chris it's interesting you
bring that up because in the Pew Center
research about half of the people polled
don't really care how they're addressed
in stores during the holidays they don't
feel one way or the other whether people
say Merry Christmas or happy holidays so
I think again that the culture is
changing and people are becoming much
more okay with how everyone wants to
express them well except on one side the
Southern Poverty Law Center which is
this shakedown racket essentially
they've all got very rich on it salting
their money away in British colonial tax
havens the SPLC hate tracker tracks as
hate phrases hashtag Christmas and
hashtag Jesus is the reason for the
season how come the hate group tracker
that's quoted by all the mainstream
media thinks hash tag Jesus is the
reason for the season is a hate phrase
it's really interesting I can't answer
that question I don't know why I really
don't I mean I think again that the
tides are changing and you know the
whole idea of saying that there was a
war on Christmas is a backlash against a
political correctness movement it
started coming out during the 1990s the
premise of the political correctness
movement as far as I understand it both
from a psychotherapists point of view
and from a journalist point of view is
about in being inclusive inclusivity so
we want to have more room at the table
of people to express themselves I mean
it doesn't necessarily mean you take a
seat away no but doesn't it it come
because like like bush houses
happy Ramadan and all the rest of it and
suddenly it's Christmas the big
mainstream thing that has to be happy
holidays by Ramadan happy Chanukah and
all the rest of it happy ID and all the
rest thank you thank you now we have to
have to run